I was defiantly naked.
So bad ass.
My name is Maya.
I'm 23 years old.
Take off the robe and look
at your body in the mirror.
Describe the feelings
and thoughts you have.
I feel shy and exposed,
but I feel beautiful. You know. Look,
my name is Kylie Bamberger.
I'm 29 years old.
Feel Feminine,
different.
My name is ash.
I'm 32 years old.
Took me a long time to love this body,
but I'm really proud of it.
My name is Giovani. I'm 23 years old.
Yeah. My body doesn't look like eight.
Uh,
it's so awkward looking just
looking at your body to be honest.
My name is chance Calloway. I'm
31 years old. It feels weird.
I guess I'm a weird person,
so I guess that's why it
feels weird being in my body.
I'm hairier than I remember.
I guess it means I'm getting old.
So, uh, do you pick or after? Yeah.
Okay.
Describe your hair when
you wake up in the morning.
Yeah,
so definitely a you question.
Well, it could be a you Ukraine.
This is what my hair looks like in the
mornings. Oh Wow. Yeah, man. So My, uh,
my morning routine is like,
I am surprised
I lost my hair when I was 15 years old.
I have alopecia is an
autoimmune hair loss disease.
I stopped wearing wigs when
hours about 20, 21 years old.
And I have decided to
embrace my hair loss.
I feel that body hair,
we use it to communicate.
We use it to identify,
but I don't think that
it defines who you are.
Hello.
Describe what you
consider the type of hair.
Oh,
okay.
Honestly.
Okay.
I love curly hair.
I've grew up with curly hair.
It's a beautiful thing because it's just
a mixture of so many cultures. My track,
like of just like three ex girlfriends
literally almost look exactly the same.
It's actually like, just, I can't even
lie. Like, do you find her sexy? I do.
I do. Honestly. Um, well,
my most ideal type of hair
would be whatever is natural.
I never altered my hair.
I never changed it,
but I was never raised with like,
hair become like makes you who you
are. Yeah. Um, so when I lost my hair,
I was almost liberated. I always
had long hair. So like we're like,
like literally polar opposites.
When you said like the hair
doesn't define who you are.
Literally for me because I grew
up with like long curly hair,
it like made me the man I am today.
My hair's been a part of me since I,
since I was born.
I've never seen my hair short.
When I was growing up I always had
my hair in braids cause it was just,
it was just the more masculine thing
to do and it was really tough and just
being called names like everybody
equates my hair to my sexuality, no suck.
That's pretty much the biggest
thing I had. Like I said,
it made me who I am and name is strong.
It made me more masculine
and thank you mom.
Honestly for just not cutting it.
Okay.
What does a bad hair
day look like for you?
With the hairline that I have,
which isn't even a line,
it's the Appalachian Mountains
back there. Um, yeah,
I don't really have like bad
hair days. It's just like, Yup,
I'm going to look like trash for
the next like week. And a half. Uh,
well for my beard it's kind of like
one side my beer. It'll be up here.
Yeah. And then everything's smooth. Yeah.
When I was first diagnosed with
polycystic ovarian syndrome,
I really didn't like my body.
I didn't like how it looked.
And I actually shaved my beard and was
terrified of letting it grow for a really
long time and I was
miserable living like that.
Um,
but you know,
it's soft and full and it's gorgeous.
It gives me more self esteem to be
able to wear it and be proud of it now.
Yeah.
Okay.
Have you ever experienced
a physical transformation?
I wish I experienced a physical chest
transformation honestly, cause uh,
one thing I'm super insecure about is
the smallness of my body calm something
like my hair versus my body.
Like it's just,
I feel like sometimes our physical
transformations can be mental,
if that makes sense. Like growing
up thinking like, oh, I'm perfect.
And then like, my mind switched, not
my body. I was still not perfect.
I was all of a sudden like,
oh, I'm perfect. Yeah.
Like that was one of the
biggest transformation. Yeah.
Up until now.
Thank you again.
So I found out that I was pregnant maybe
two weeks ago and I'm a little nervous
because I never like reached that whole
dream body stage and I'm a photographer,
so I just really want to reach it for like
one second so I can take some pictures
before.
Um,
but now I feel like I might not get
that chance because they will be stretch
marks on my, tell me very soon, but
that's okay too because
there's going to be,
they really can appeal.
Course it is.
Have you ever waxed any part of your
body and was it worth it if you did?
I can start. Uh, no
god, I have like bad experiences with
waxing. My mom like insisted, oh,
we have to wax it off and
everything and like, you know,
she just didn't want me to
be made fun of in school,
but it made me feel like,
you know,
I was a freak and I had this huge secret
I had to keep from everybody. And,
uh,
you know,
one day I'd had still bullies and
like nobody really said anything.
And I was like, okay, well let's keep
this going and see how far I can go.
Probably one of the happiest moments for
me was when I finally had kind of like
a small beard. One of my friends,
he's this big like Viking looking guy.
He just took me up in this huge bear hug
and he whispered in my air and was just
like, you look beautiful and like
I love this and keep growing it.
I was like the real life changing
experience. Yeah. Cause it was,
who is like the first moment
that somebody accepted it,
like out loud and you know,
I'm like trying to not cry but um,
but yeah.
And so ever since then it's just been
so much better and it's been so freeing.
I walked in the room and like,
the first thing I saw was actually
you and your smile and it's like,
I'm truly happy that you embrace
it. It seems too, thank you.
It's curvy as I am and it's Harry as I am.
I'm like,
I still find myself incredibly beautiful.
I'm really grateful for
how much I stand out.
I feel like I'm able to make more of
an impact. Um, just meeting a person,
um,
that I would if I wasn't so different.
I don't remember who made the last,
I don't even know how to
describe a physical state of
the person across from you
that you had
your smile. Oh, I keep seeing
it. I was like, oh my gosh, the keels oil.
It's really hard for me to
receive, but I'm, I've been
working on that. Yeah. Yeah.
You, your skin, you have that wonderful,
that kind of like that glowy kind of like,
you know, pregnant. Is that what it was?
I believe that everything that's physical,
you know, it's tied also to like, you
know, the stuff that you can't see. Right.
It's, you know, it's fantastic.
So that that's tied to
something that you can't see.
Cause I totally feel the
same about your smile.
I feel like that's tied
directly to your heart.
Oh,
I mean,
I'm never really satisfied.
I'm always either too
skinny or too overweight.
I definitely wish my hair wasn't
sua receding because let's be real.
My hair was like a point of pride when
I was a kid. It's, I guess my body.
I'll be like, what else do you want from
me? You know, it's been giving me a lot.
Do you want a cow?
Sorry.
Share a struggle that you've experienced
in life that involves your body.
I would say I think all of
my body struggles would have
to be with my hair loss,
um, and losing femininity.
Even to this day,
I'm approached as saying, excuse me sir,
how can I, how can I help you? Yeah.
Um, every day while you're working
on changing what people think,
it's a struggle, but that's like,
that's like what drives me, you know? I,
I like the saying,
you can't control what others do,
but you can control how you react.
I stopped going to the gym for a
long time because in the shower room,
like I would have lady's yelling at me.
So I stepped out completely
naked and I was like,
is there something wrong?
And it was a terrifying experience,
but at the same time it's
like I was defiantly naked,
which like I, you know, I have
certain insecurities and things,
but on the other hand it's,
I was taking the power away from that.
That is so bad ass.
No,
seriously find like embracing
who you are as a whole,
however that may be is just so bad ass.
Some days it feels like you are an alien.
The most exotic thing
that anyone has ever seen.
Ooh,
some days the only thing
you Alyssa is sympathy.
Pity.
Some days you change people's minds.
I feel like my body is
as perfect as it can be.
You know when you're
able to accept yourself,
your body feels lighter and your body
feels more complete and I wouldn't change
it for the world.
Hey guys, this is John from jubilee.
Thank you so much for watching this video.
We hope you guys enjoy it.
There's any topics that have to do with
bodies that you want us to do an episode
on. We'd love to hear that as well,
and as always, please be sure to click,
subscribe and follow us on Instagram.
Peace.